elasticsearch versus aws it's a battle
between the billion dollar david
and the trillion dollar goliath and the
outcome could have a huge influence on
the future of open source software as we
know it
in today's video we'll talk about the
drama surrounding amazon and elastic
but more importantly you'll learn how
open source software actually works from
a legal perspective and why if you're a
business that uses open source software
the license granted to you by the
creator and does actually matter
if you're new here like and subscribe
and let me know what you think about all
this drama in the comments
as of last week elasticsearch will no
longer be free open source software
going forward it'll have a dual license
one of which is proprietary
and the other is sspl which is commonly
known as a fopen source license
this change is a big deal because
elastic used to be licensed under apache
2.0 which allows commercial use with
very few restrictions
the server side public license or sspl
on the other hand
has restrictions on what you can do with
the software commercially now the vast
majority of current elastic users can
still use the software without any
negative impact
however if you're someone like aws that
offers a fully managed elastic search
service
you can no longer use future releases of
the software to provide that service
for example if i wanted to launch a
startup called jeff's elasticsearch
service
i wouldn't be able to legally do that
without permission from the company
so basically the license is a way to
limit the dominance of big cloud
providers
but in the process it also screws over
another group of people
anybody who's contributed to the
elasticsearch code base over the last 10
years
when you write code for an open source
project you do it under a specific
license
and most often you're doing it unpaid in
your free time with the expectation that
that software will remain
free and open source throughout its
lifetime when a company goes to a more
restrictive license it's like pulling
the rug out from under you
gotcha [ __ ] there's nothing illegal
about it but it's like saying hey thanks
for your contribution your code is now
proprietary we're gonna make a ton of
money off it
pay you absolutely nothing and not let
you build a business from our software
going forward
that's a pretty lame deal if you ask me
and elastic knows this which begs the
question
why would they make such an unfair
change in the first place like most
things in life
it comes down to the money amazon is
profitable and makes tons of money in
the cloud with a 1.6 trillion dollar
market cap
meanwhile elastic has a meager 15
billion market cap and is nowhere near
profitability
i drink your milkshake
i drink it up don't bully me elastic has
argued that aws has been doing things
that are
quote not okay since 2015. some of the
alleged unethical behavior
includes using elastic's trademarks
without authorization
copying features offered in elastics
cloud product and copy and proprietary
code to use in amazon's opendistro for
elasticsearch
and in a broader sense just using and
profiting from the open source software
without giving back enough to the
community inelastic is not the first
high-profile tech company to have
issues with aws mongodb is actually the
original pioneer of the sspl license
they had similar complaints and wanted
to restrict the power of cloud companies
to offer their software
as a service it's no secret that big
tech companies steal
or get inspired i should say by the
features offered by other companies
all of instagram's features are stolen
from snapchat and the same dynamic works
in the cloud
mostly between the big three companies
trying to match each other in feature
parity
and elastic is just one small part of a
much bigger system
at the end of the day though it ends up
being a lose-lose situation for elastic
had they remained open source developers
would still love them but aws would
continue to drink their milkshake
but by making the licensing change they
pissed off a bunch of open source
developers
and on top of that amazon called their
bluff you don't become the king by being
a nice guy
instead of saying okay elastic we'll
shut down our service or pay you for a
license
amazon said fork you bro we're just
going to fork your project
and maintain it as an open source
project going forward where we call all
the shots
which means going forward there are
basically two versions of elasticsearch
out in the world
there's the original official one with a
restricted license and the new
amazon fork with the original apache 2.0
license
the move to fork the project was
expected because when mongodb
changed their license a couple of years
ago amazon quickly created their own
service called documentdb
which is technically a different
database but fully compatible with
mongodb
amazon is big and powerful enough to
just whip up a service like this on the
fly to circumvent any damage from a
licensing change so it really makes me
wonder what elastic really has to gain
from this move
maybe i'm missing something and let me
know in the comments but it seems like
the only thing that elastic has actually
gained from this move is negative press
i put a pull out on twitter and two out
of three people would prefer to use the
aws fork
over the original proprietary software
in any case let's take a step back for a
minute
to understand what open source software
really is and how it affects you as a
developer or entrepreneur
the authority on open source is the open
source initiative which has been around
since the late 90s and is governed by a
board of directors
it's not controlled or anything like
that it's just the accepted organization
by the greater tech industry now in
order for a software to be considered
open source
it needs to follow the tent principle
shown here we're not going to go through
all of them
but in a nutshell the software needs to
be free to use and distribute for
any purpose including commercial uses
now if you want to offer open source
software to the world
you'll attach a license to your project
and there are a bunch of different
licenses out there
some of the most popular include apache
mit
and gpl my personal favorite is the mit
license which is very short and
basically just says do whatever the hell
you want
then the apache license which is also
very popular and what elasticsearch
formerly used
is also very permissive but basically
says do whatever you want just don't sue
me and then you might have slightly more
restrictive options like gpl
which say that if you make a derivative
work then you also need to share it
under an open source license
and sometimes big companies don't like
that because they want to take open
source software and make it proprietary
now when working with an open source
project you'll most often do that on
github for any given project you should
see the license and the root of the
repository
and github should give you a nice little
breakdown of the actual bullet points in
the legal jargon itself
if you're building a business with open
source software it's worth understanding
what the license actually means
because that could come back to bite you
in a big way down the road
now another thing worth pointing out is
that when you contribute to open source
software
you may also be required to sign a
contributor license agreement this is
like the reverse
of the project license it's an agreement
made by you the contributor
allowing the company that owns the repo
to do certain things with your code
they're usually only required by big
companies that have big legal teams that
can manage them
at the end of the day open source is
awesome because it creates an ecosystem
where developers and companies can
innovate much faster
but you may be wondering how does anyone
make money off of open source software
if you build something awesome making it
open source might seem
counterproductive if your goal is to
make money surprisingly there are a
variety of highly successful business
models
built on open source one example is ruby
on rails
it's an application framework that was
used to build many high-profile
companies like twitter and shopify
but it was created by a lesser-known
company called basecamp the popularity
of rails
indirectly helped basecamp grow because
it brought them a ton of positive
attention
and created a huge community of open
source developers helping make the
framework better
in other words it turned out to be a
great organic marketing tool for
building
a bigger brand but there are more direct
ways to make money with open source
one of which is in the form of
consulting my friends over at narwhal
created the nx framework for managing
large enterprise web applications
it's open source but if you're a large
enterprise that wants to use this
framework
who better than to consult you on it
than the company that created it
although the software is free the
consulting fees are not red hat also
follows a similar model with billions of
dollars in revenue
but another way to make money is to
offer your software as a hosted service
in the cloud
often with extra features that you can't
get from the main open source software
this is the approach that elastic is
taking where they offer additional
features
like security aimed at enterprise
clients because that's where the money
is
and another example is wordpress the
most popular blog builder in the world
even though it's open sourced the
company also offers their own hosted
service
that makes it much easier to set up
configure and host a wordpress blog
and who would you rather pay for that
service than the company who created the
original software
so to recap there are three basic ways
to make money from open source in my
opinion
use it as a marketing tool use it to
gain consulting clients
or use it to build your own paid service
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there
but before you go make sure to let me
know what you think about all this stuff
in the comments
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one